welcome back council flights are leaving
tens of thousands of americans
frustrated and stranded in airports
across the country but at the southern
border illegal migrants have no problem
catching the flight pennsylvania is the
latest state seeing an influx of ghost
flights coming in the middle of the
night full of illegal immigrants
according to a letter sent to homeland
secretary by congressman dan moore
hundreds of illegal migrants have been
flowing into scranton international
airport by u.s government charter flight
and this isn't the first time we're
hearing about it we've heard senator we
heard about similar stories coming out
of jacksonville florida earlier in
november here now to react to fox nation
host thomas baron uh tommy you know
anything that happens in the night can't
be trustworthy especially when it's
coming from the u.s government
so
why are they doing this
well i think it's quite obvious they
don't want the american people to see
what they're doing which is interesting
to me because they don't seem to care
that our border is wide open they don't
seem to want to fix that in fact they
seem quite proud of what they're doing
at our southern border if they weren't
then they would change it so then why
fly these flights in the middle of the
night why are these biden air flights
ghost flights as you say if they're so
proud of their open border agenda then
let the american people see it but too
bad i think that they realize the
american people are not down with this
invasion they're not okay with our
country being invaded by millions of
illegal immigrants so they have to do
this by night tactic
too bad we're starting to catch on you
know
we're catching on it's reflective in in
the polls tommy so they have to know
about how the american people feel i
mean even if you look at democrat
cities that are on the border that have
flipped to republican now and still
after all of that they won't listen to
henry cuellar a democrat who has been
encouraging the biden administration to
do something about the board they won't
listen to the polls
so do they just not care or is their
larger mission
more important
yeah the larger mission is to import
their future voters they know they're
losing with the american people so they
want to pad their voting block that's
been my theory for years now but the
bind administration is not going to
change their policy that's clear so it's
going to be up to governors both
republican and democrat as you mentioned
lawrence to start making changes ron
desantis has already vowed that he's
going to spend money in his state to
send these illegal immigrants to blue
states he's also going to make sure that
those non-profits and those private
companies that are aiding and abetting
this activity are also held accountable
and paying restitution to the taxpayers
that are footing the bill for all of
this so we need more governors like ron
desantis i don't care if they have an r
or a d behind their name they need to
stand up their constituents and they
need to stand up for the american people
yeah
you know it's just interesting to me
that you continue to hear compassion
from this party
and you see what's happening to these
kids but you also see
the drug crisis is happening and it's
coming from the board of course mexico
is getting a lot of that stuff from
china but there's a direct route i mean
whether you're talking about the drugs
the the the people that they are selling
to sex slavery or the illegal migrants
it's all one uh pile of nonsense that is
hurting american people
even if we're not talking about the
drugs and the criminals that are
undoubtedly coming across our border we
also need to take a look at this
realistically and logically and
understand that even if these people are
coming in even if they're unaccompanied
minors even if they're people that are
just looking for a better life which we
sympathize with we understand but those
people are still draining our resources
they're still costing us money they're
still draining education resources law
enforcement infrastructure all of those
things to the detriment of the american
people there are so many children in
states across this country who don't
have the resources that they need in
their schools or in their homes and
meanwhile we're footing the bill for
people who have no legal right to be
here also the biden administration can
import more future voters now the
american people are not going to be
happy with this and i think you're going
to see it come november yeah
and it's funny because then you have the
bite administration that is so petty
texas decided to build its own border
wall and the pile of stuff that's
already paid for by the u.s taxpayers
they wouldn't even sell it to texas
that's that's that's that's where the
biden administration is right there they
choose pettiness instead of the rule of
all tommy lahren thanks so much for
joining me tonight
thanks laurence happy new year